today we're going to be speaking with
Steve Schmidt who's a renowned American
political strategist formerly of the
2008 McCain campaign and many other
campaigns founder of the warning a
newsletter podcast and YouTube channel
as well uh Steve great to have you on I
appreciate your time
good to be with you my pleasure so where
are you on the Republican party at this
point in time I'm curious because your
views have certainly evolved over time I
mean our audience may may or may not
know about them
well I founded the Lincoln project in
2020 to oppose Donald Trump I was uh
Arnold Schwarzenegger's campaign manager
I was a top strategist for George W bush
I served in the bush white house but I
have always recognized that Donald Trump
was a profound threat to the Republic
along with every other person in the
Republican Party the difference is uh a
few of us when we said never meant it uh
and overwhelmingly as in 99.99
of every person involved in the
institutional Republican party allowed
themselves to capitulate appease what I
regard as the most dangerous threat that
the country has faced uh internally
since the Civil War and what I viewed
Republican party as as a in a two-party
system in this country is a profound
threat that has been hijacked by a
faction that has turned against
fundamental American Concepts such as
democracy and pluralism and all of it uh
is is deeply ground in walking away from
the results of an election and I just
last thing I'll say about that I'm the
person who placed the phone call for
John McCain to Barack Obama
um and uh you know I was the first
Republican in America to say the words
congratulations Mr president-elect
before I handed the phone to them and so
this is Elemental in a free society and
that's what the parties walked away from
so as far as policy goes I mean are you
still like a low tax guy you want to
reduce abortion or have your views also
changed over time I was a moderate
republican from New Jersey right so the
northeastern tradition of republicanism
was not ideological it wasn't Southern
it wasn't Evangelical the Republican
Party in the northeastern states was a
Reform Party and it typically took power
after the excesses of the machine run
party controlled Democrats of those
States so you always had
non-ideological Republicans Jacob Javits
Christy Whitman Tom Kane in New Jersey
that ran on records of of
environmentalism I've always
supported a woman's right to choose and
I was one of the very earliest people
um with any profile in the country to
come out in favor of gay marriage in the
Republican party I I worked for the ACLU
leading the marriage equality campaigns
I don't think that you can look
seriously into account camera as a
Republican and say hey this is a
fiscally conservative party there is no
fiscally conservative party in America
you have two wildly spending political
parties that have accumulated 32
trillion dollars in national debt
um if you look at the baby boomer
presidencies Bill Clinton was the most
fiscally responsible Barack Obama was
number two George Bush was number three
and Donald Trump was the wildest spender
of them all when it cut you mentioned
New Jersey you know when I look at the
Republican primary field now as a guy
from the progressive left it seems so
obvious to me that Chris Christie is by
far the most competent and qualified
person running in that primary and if
you said to me David the next president
will be someone currently running in the
Republican primary it would be so
obvious to me that Chris Christie would
be my choice he's polling one percent
okay we don't yet have polling from
after his announcement what is your
sense of whether there is any desire
among the current Republican party for
someone like a Chris Christie
well I look I think it is a mistake for
people to look at Chris Christie and
just to Lively say he has no chance
reality is
in order to win the Republican
nomination
you have to win somewhere first
so when you look at this right now
could Tim Scott win in Iowa Tim Scott
can win in Iowa
I think he's the only person who can
beat Trump in Iowa who's in the field
right now can Chris Christie win in New
Hampshire is it possible if if you look
at Chris Christie's Town Hall from the
other night and you look for example at
Tim Ryan's Town Hall that he did on Fox
News and he basically said many of the
same things that Chris Christie did you
watch that fox audience and people's
faces are contorted and twisted in Anger
as he's telling them right that Trump
lost the election you got the guy with
the Maga hat no we saw the Trump town
hall on CNN when people are cheering
because Trump had just been found guilty
of sexual abuse and defamation right you
didn't see any of that in that audience
in New Hampshire right of people who
turned out to Chris Christie right you
if you watch that closely on a body
language perspective
those people are not rejecting what he's
saying so now however it is that that
Chris got there right over seven long
years and I'm gonna I'm gonna step I'm
gonna I'm just gonna skip that whole
part of it because I I think it's
tedious we all we all know his record
his Stepford Wife appearance but he's
the only person in the race
such as it is who's just telling the
truth right now now he hasn't always
been truthful on these issues to say to
say the least but right in the race
right now he's our guy he's your guy
he's my guy because he's the only guy
who's saying things that heretofore no
one has said to these audiences any
person who's who's running uh have lived
in a delusion sphere and good for Chris
Christie better late than never is a
saying for a reason you know that he's
bringing up the Manifest corruption and
all the other all the other issues is he
flawed of course he is flawed but you
know it's he's the best that they got
right now and there is a truth teller in
the race and and that hasn't been the
case the only group that that has ever
confronted him effectively is the group
that I started it it indisputably drew
blood in the in the sixth year of
Trump's presence on the national stage
so in terms I hope Chris Christie can do
that in terms of the other non-trump
people that are running we've seen
pretty significant hesitation to really
go after Trump Christy and his town hall
was direct and he said the path to the
nomination is through Trump and Trump's
going to try to go through me I'm going
to try to go through him with everybody
else you know Nikki Haley early on would
basically just chalk it up to I'm a
woman and I'm younger and I'm a person
of color and Tim Scott when he was given
the opportunity to really draw
distinctions with Trump sort of said the
contrast is going to be clear and what
exactly he meant by that I don't know
what what he meant DeSantis is starting
to criticize Trump a little but it seems
that there's this idea that if they are
there
and then Trump gets arrested three more
times and maybe it pulls him off the
campaign Trail they will be able to
swoop in and somehow pick up Trump
supporters by virtue of not having
really attacked Trump at this early
stage is that viable and number two if
it is it can't be viable for all of them
it seems maybe for one of them that
would work
it's it's not viable for any of them
look at the end of the day it's a
position that's rooted in a fundamental
delusional dishonesty and if you look at
what a presidential contest is
the race for the presidency in the
United States is the greatest
non-lethal competition in the world
there's nothing there is nothing like it
there there is no game there is no sport
there is nothing that is as intense as
focused as this and so what this is as
David Axelrod once said is an MRI for
the soul right this is a character test
and so each of these people right put
aside their beliefs their ideology their
political label they're weak and they're
afraid they're terrified of being
tweeted about by Donald Trump Mike
Pence's race has no rationale whatsoever
his former boss the president tried to
have him hung and and he just now will
only say well he endangered me and
others and my family yeah the the
American people in in our full range of
our vast Menagerie right of beliefs in
everything else
from left to right
the American people will not vote for
weaklings will not vote for
spinelessness right so so every one of
these people and exclusively right
they're all the people that played a
previous role as Trump sycophants who
won't tell the truth about him now what
they what they prove is their softness
and it's disqualifying so all of these
people whether it's the North Dakota
governor who could let's say right and
I've never seen the guy I couldn't pick
him out of a lineup I don't know if he's
good or not he can talk or not but but
could there be a reform-minded governor
from a small state in the tradition of a
Jimmy Carter in 1976 is there space for
that in the Republican party there is
but you asked the North Dakota governor
right well what about his claims about
the stolen election right what about him
saying this ah you won't say a word it's
like he's in the witness protection Pro
program right you know he's like facing
down Pablo Escobar at trial he won't
NADA right right and it's disqualifying
when it comes to the economy there's
been this idea for a long time in
American politics that when you look at
a re-election of a sitting president so
much of it is Guided by the state of the
economy however there's this strange
thing happening right now
where on Monday I looked at every
indicator that's usually used how has
the stock market been doing what's the
unemployment rate job creation numbers
GDP inflation trade balance right we
look at all of it it all looks pretty
okay unremarkable or like pretty good
and yet all the time on my YouTube
channel I see comments from people
saying you're you're worried because the
economy is a disaster Biden has failed
on the economy and when I say well show
me a metric that proves that people will
write to me they'll say well if you
compare wages to housing costs we're
looking pretty deep here to find
something that would point to an economy
that's not at minimum okay if not
cruising along pretty pretty well what's
your view on this issue maybe not so
much about the the state of the economy
but the disconnect about even if the
metrics look fine the story is still
that the economy is terrible what I
would say what I would say about that is
what you're talking about is the
difference between emotion and
rationality right and so the so the
question you're asking is a question
about a feeling right not a not a
question about the weather right so you
go outside it's 85 degrees and sunny and
someone says this is a terrible day you
look at them and you say it's obviously
not it's a beautiful day right but but
but this is much more subjective right
so first off
um and you look at some of the ratings
decline on cable for example cable news
um it makes perfect sense I mean 80
percent of the people that appear on CNN
for example on any given day are
appearing from Washington D.C and almost
none of those people make under a couple
of million dollars a year
so so they are in a place that is
detached from reality they live in a
rarified air and there is a lack of
appreciation across the board for the
fact that 40 percent of the country
doesn't have 400 cash available that
enormous percentages of the
e123e4 ranks in the military deal with
food insecurity issues
um go look at the paid day lending
outside of a military base does any
normal person have access to a return on
the stock market in the sense of here's
a stock this company has a value it's
going to grow this is all computer
trading against algorithms at the edge
of a moment of profound disruption
caused by technology
globalization and there's a lack of an
animating Vision
um that communicates to people what's
what's going to happen next so I think
that all of Biden's deficiencies
um in in a political sense are rooted in
a in an awful failure of communications
and and that is and that is where that
is very very worrying right if you're if
you're a football team you have to throw
the ball if you're the president of the
United States running for re-election in
a fraud time against a massive massive
massive massive misinformation
propaganda Network all of it put
together you have to communicate like
Tom Brady throws at football and and
even the most generous generous fan of
the of the president has to understand
has to appreciate that that there is a
massive communication deficit in the in
the evidence of that is that this
radical extremist anti-American movement
has not been crushed politically it's
still alive and it's still in a position
to take power in this next election has
to be the place where it's put away for
good we've been speaking with political
strategist Steve Schmidt he is the
founder of the warning and we will link
to the newsletter podcast and YouTube
channel Steve really appreciate your
time and insights today
my pleasure to be with you